[Music]
Forest Whitaker talked to et at the
premiere of his new film the forgiving
about how he'd want to return for a
black panther sequel black panther has
been blowing up I mean it's one of the
most successful films we obviously know
the fate of your character but if you
could write your own sequel if you could
write yourself into the sequel what
would you do how would you picture those
I guess I would be like an obi-wan
Kenobi or something you know because of
a cute oxygen from the ancestral plane
to give advice to to T'Challa
Chadwicks character Chadwicks amazing
from ryan coogler is such an amazing job
so so proud to be in it for his new
movie Forrest underwent a major makeover
in his role as Archbishop Desmond Tutu
chemisty your crimes tell me what that
transformation was like every day on set
it was more difficult to try to find and
keep the center of Desmond Tutu they
sort of I don't say calm but graceful
way in which he looks at the world did
you actually get his blessing did you
talk at all to Desmond for sure I mean I
had met him before but this time it was
different because you know I was trying
to understand the man and I I knew his
laughs I knew it
his sense of humor I knew how I felt his
passion his faith you know to me but
trying to trying to capture it by
sitting with him so I I said with him in
his home I said with him at his office's
we talked quite a bit and it was it was
very helpful to me it loves the film I
was quite moved because I've been really
scared about it you know because he
impresses me so much I was worried that
I wouldn't reach what he wanted in his
expectations but he wrote an amazing
amazing note about the film
[Music]